the apple smartwatch finally just got
competition in may of 2022 google senior
vice president of device and services
rick osterlow showed off the
much-anticipated pixel watch on stage at
the company's io there's a lot you
should know concerning what google
disclosed to us about the watch and i'm
here to tell you all of it in this short
video the pixel watch design
nothing beats a smartwatch or any
wearable than the cosmetic feature and
google knows this firsthand the company
revealed the pixel watch will have a
circular round face and a dome design
with glass which will make it look a bit
curved over the edges that's different
from the apple watch which is
rectangular in shape i'm picturing the
google pixel smartwatch and yup that's
going to look a whole lot better than a
square sitting on my wrist although the
bezels look a bit thick so let's keep
our eyes peeled for what that display
experience will be like the material
google plans on using is recycled
stainless steel which is the same as
apple and of course you're going to have
customized straps with colors which is
pretty neat the pixel watch tech
the google pixel smartwatch will be a
tech treat first off the smartwatch is
going to have a tactile crown that
allows you to navigate without touching
your screen meanwhile touchscreen and
voice are also other means of input and
navigation also the google pixel
smartwatch will be an android compatible
one it will run google wear os with a
refreshed fluid interface a little
birdie told me it will run its wear os
software and will support tasks such as
tap to pay navigating google maps google
wallet maps and receiving notifications
it will also be controlled by google's
voice assistant and a tactile crown on
the side similar to how the apple watch
is controlled by siri and the digital
crown google like apple will offer a
version with 4g cellular connectivity so
that you can activate controls without a
device what's more it seems like you'll
be able to access google home controls
with this smartwatch as well fluid
interface smooth navigation you can be
sure google will tick off all the smart
wearable boxes with this baby what's
impressive is how the watch will work
like a remote to control music and media
connected with your other pixel devices
that's right all that control right
there on your wrist no taking out your
phone in a crowded place or anywhere but
ask any google rep to verify this and
their lips are sealed according to rick
osterload the smartwatch will have a
refreshed fluid interface that will be
easy to navigate if there is one major
feature i look for in a smartwatch it's
a health tracker and the google pixel
smartwatch isn't going to leave that out
now i'm not talking about google fit
here i'm talking about google's health
and fitness integration via fitbit
google acquired the fitness tracking
company in november 2019 for a whopping
2.1 billion dollars and passed on all of
the elegance of fitbit to its devices
this means that the google pixel
smartwatch will track your activity
especially if you have a fitbit account
and accompanying app fitbit integration
of the pixel smartwatch is going to make
it the first google branded product to
compete directly against the apple watch
and samsung galaxy watch in the premium
wearable space android only
the pixel watch will be available in
both bluetooth and cellular models but
there is a catch you must pair your
watch with a device running android 8.0
or later and the watch will also require
a google account while this is unlikely
to be an issue for existing android or
google fans it does mean that the pixel
watch will not be compatible with
iphones and moreover that's also part of
the reason why google isn't promoting
the pixel smartwatch as a replacement to
fitbit's products considering fitbit's
watches and trackers work with both ios
and android apple ecosystem versus
google ecosystem so a pixel tablet that
integrates with a pixel phone that
communicates with a chromebook and pixel
watch is beginning to sound very much
like an alternate reality where google
becomes apple google's pixel watch will
be another grandbaby in the ever-growing
google ecosystem which might soon give
apple a serious run for their money we
still don't know much about the pixel
watch but we expect to learn more in the
coming months in reality even a
phenomenal pixel watch will not be able
to dethrone the apple watch in a year
apple has far too large a lead the pixel
6 series was extremely popular for a
google smartphone and had no effect on
iphone 13 sales the pixel watch will be
no different however google is laying
the groundwork for its products and the
android based industry to maintain and
possibly gain market share from apple
which has been on a tear in recent years
the supply chain is the only thing
holding it back but make no mistake the
pixel watch could be the first true
apple watch competitor to turn the tide
in the war of the ecosystems
well well come on now if you're going to
shell out 400 for an apple premium
product 250 for a samsung then can you
expect google to be in the lower range
no way the google pixel smartwatch reads
premium all over its classy round face
and you can expect a premium price and
this has been confirmed by google
themselves so although we don't have a
number yet it's definitely going to be
premium google hardware upgrades the
smartwatch market is fairly saturated
with apple accounting for roughly 30 of
sales according to counterpoint research
samsung electronics co holds 10 of the
market while the rest is made up of
fitbit garmin limited and smaller
china-based players like huawei
technologies co while google's hardware
business has yet to become a significant
revenue contributor since the launch of
the first pixel phone in 2016 the
company has continued to reveal new
phones and other devices on an annual
basis last year's pixel 6 was google's
most successful device to date
outselling previous generations of the
phone the company does not reveal its
hardware revenue but last year google's
other revenue which includes hardware
app store sales and video subscriptions
totaled more than 28 billion dollars if
you enjoyed this video click one on the
screen for more like this and i'll see
you there